ماذا قال مسؤول رفيع في الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الاتفاق الموقع في جده بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ليس
وقفا فعاله للقتال لكنه يشكل خطوه على هذا
الطريق حسب تعبيره واضف المسؤول في حطه
صحفيه الاتفاق هو وقف مؤقت للقتال يسمح
بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه وقال ان واشنطن
لا تعتقد ان الطرفين جاهزان لوقف شامل
لاطلاق النار وقال المسؤول انه تم تطوير
اليه اكثر فعاليه لمراقبه وقف القتال
بمساعده واشراف واشراف دولي على حد تعبيره
واضاف ان الاليه تشمل ثلاثه عناصر وهي
المراقبه عبر الاقمار الصناعيه والتقارير
على الارض
ومراقبه ماء ينشر على الانترنت واشار الى
انه بالاضافه لتامين استمرار المحادثات
بين طرفين المتحاربين فان واشنطن تعمل على
توسعتها لتشمل القاده المدنيين واكد ان
واشنطن تعمل مع حلفائها خطوه بخطوه لصالح
استعاده
مساهمه الحكومه المدنيه في الاتفاق اضاف
المسؤول الامريكيا اعلان جده يقضي بانسحاب
القوات العسكريه والامنيه من المستشفيات
والقيام بدفن الجثث كما يقضي الاعلان
بالسماح بوصول المساعدات واسعاده الخدمات
المدنيه الاساسيه من كهرباء وماء